sky i'm sure you guys have seen social
dilemma yanni and i've spoken about
social dilemma
um can you just scroll down a little bit
this is uh tim kendall
who used to be a big wig at facebook now
he has a a a company called
moment which i just signed up for this
this is actually a good company first of
all tim kendall will get soft the kiss
in the lips she's a cutie with a booty
um i signed up for this this is good
this is a
it's a company that helps you uh kind of
wean off your phone
it gives you a lot of tips and helps you
gives guidelines so you're
so you can break the addiction to your
phone break that phone habit so what
he's saying is
his extreme outcomes are the logical and
conclusion if there is no action on
social media reform
increasing destabilization of civil
society so what he's saying is
is if this continues with the social
media we're going to go into civil war
now what he's saying is that these
social media companies or big he calls
it big tech like
like big tobacco would just push
cigarettes on you knowing it was going
to give you cancer
big auto which is pushing cars on you
knowing that it gives fossil fuels and
it's depleting
the natural resources of our planet now
big tech
what they're doing is they're
capitalizing on
our need on our they're capitalizing on
our attention spans and now the way that
they get us to pay more attention and
click more ads and have more viewership
on their social media sites or internet
sites
is by causing division is by sending us
articles
that are going to cause more division
that are going to that are going to give
us more problems and solutions
because the solutions people figure it
out and then they don't want to be on
the computer anymore
but the more that they divide us the
more money they'll make
so the same way tobacco companies are
saying smoke cigarettes it's good for
you
you know your wife will know you're
cheating on if you smoke a [ __ ]
parliament
you'll get away with it that's what they
say yeah on this big tech stuff now now
they'll say all of a sudden
oh yeah no you need the computer it's
going to help you with this can help you
that no it's dividing you and the only
way
according to cutie with the booty tim
kendall that it stops is we have to
regulate the government has to come in
and regulate this they have to pay more
taxes they
somebody has to step in which i think
that there's a big movement now
on on stepping in and stopping these
companies
from having these monopolies and being
able to send the people whatever they
want
it's unchecked it needs to be regulated
so you know it's a big issue and i think
we know that i think most
most people now who are paying attention
know that it's like yeah of course
why what incentive does it give facebook
to send a video that's showing that's
solving racism or that's saying hey
actually the the facts suggest the
systemic racism is not as
bad as you think in america compared to
other places what's the incentive on
that
people have a conversation close the
laptop put their phone down and have a
conversation no because then you can't
buy ads for [ __ ] target
how are you going to buy how you're
going to buy new swim shorts
if you're sitting with your family with
your phone down because you're engaged
in a good healthy conversation
about how the problems aren't actually
what you think
it's you know they don't want you to do
that so they're going to continue with
the [ __ ]
i don't believe anything now anything
even on instagram
somebody who says like oh i received a
racist message or i received a sexist
message i don't believe it i don't
believe it at all
it's all bots to me it has to physically
happen in the physical realm now for me
to believe it's real
that's just what it is that's just i i
have to i don't care even the edited
clips
i don't care i don't believe it at all
anymore a trained eye can quickly tell
whether an instagram account is operated
by a human or a bot
nevertheless the image network has
failed to get its bot problem under
control a new study mentions the
existence of
95 million bot accounts on instagram
95 million bots on instagram
all that that's how many bots are off
you know so
just do the math what's the population
of moscow i don't know might be 95
million
might be what's the population of
beijing what's up
how many people live in one apartment
building in beijing might be 95 million
i'm just saying crispy communism thank
you so much for watching hope you
enjoyed the last video
don't forget to tell your friends like
subscribe and turn on notifications